بعد لحظات الزلزال العصيبه تتركز الجهود
في المرحله الاولى للاستجابه للكارثه على
البحث عن الناجين وانقاذ العدد الاكبر من
الارواح يستعان في ذلك بمجموعه من المعدات
تعجل بالوصول لاماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض
وفجوات الركام مثل نظام دار القادر على
رصد الاجسام الثابته والمتحركه عبر
الخرسانه المسلحه ومعدات الصوت الحساسه
والكاميرات الحراريه وايضا الكلاب المدربه
تستمر هذه المرحله ما بين خمسه الى سبعه
ايام
ارتضائل فرص العثور على احياء بعد ذلك لكن
استمرار البحث عن المتبقي من الناجين
واستمرارا انتشال جثامين الضحايا ودفنهم
قد يستمر لايام اطول ثم تاتي مرحله
الاغاثه الطارئه تتوجه الجهود هنا نحو
تقديم المساعده العاجله لمن شردتهم الكار
وتشمل تامين الماوى المؤقت وتوفير الماء
والغذاء اضافه الى رعايه الطبيه
والاسعافات الاوليه مده هذه المرحله تطول
او تقصر بحسب حجم المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال والامكانات المتاحه لفرق الاغاثه
بعد ذلك ينتقل الى المرحله الاخيره مرحله
التعافي التي تبدا بايجاد ماوى للعائلات
المنكوبه يكون قادرا على تحمل الظروف
الجويه كالامطار والرياح مع توفر امكانيه
الوصول للمياه والغذاء ليتم الانتقال بعد
ذلك الى فحص المباني المتضرره وازاله
الخطر منها ثم العمل على ازاله الركام
والانقاض والبدء باصلاح شبكات الصرف الصحي
والمياهي والكهرباء وقد تستمر هذه المرحله
سنوات للتخلص من كافه اثار الزلزال